welcome to
back to work school and life utility of
covid19 testing to help communities
restore a sense of normality
my name is patti love and i'm your host
for this workshop
in this workshop we will focus on
increased testing
and how it can help restore communities
to a sense of normal
or the new normal i have two terrific
speakers with me
today one will give an example of how
university has established a
surveillance program for students at the
university
with our techpath kovid19 assay
and the other comes in from the industry
perspective
with an at-home test in different areas
that where consumer testing can have
impact such as at home sporting events
or tourism by the end of this section i
hope you'll come away with effective
strategies for establishing potential
testing channels
operational considerations you may
encounter and a couple testing solutions
that are available to you from thermo
fisher scientific today
i'd like to start by introducing
professor jared au claire who leads the
surveillance program for students
at northeastern university faculty is
the associate dean of professional
program in the college of science
an associate teaching professor in the
department of chemistry and chemical
biology professor alclair also serves as
the technical supervisor for the life
science testing center at northeastern
university
which is a state and clia certified lab
in addition professor eau claire is
active on the global stage as the
director of the
biopharmaceutical analysis laboratory
otherwise known as battle
the asia-pacific economic cooperation
center
of regulatory excellence in
biotherapeutics and advanced therapies
and oversees the international council
for harmonization training
these appointments allow dr claire to
collaborate with both academic
researchers
and industry in the areas of
biopharmaceutical development and
analysis
as well as international regulators on
best practices and new advances
in regulatory sciences for drug
approvals
dr ercler received his bachelor's degree
in biotechnology from wpi
and a phd in biomedical science from the
university of massachusetts medical
in both instances dr clare's research
focused on
understanding the molecular mechanism of
hiv one
upon graduating with his phd he did a
postdoc under greg petsco
dak maringe and jeffrey agar at brandeis
university
dr clare i pass it off to you thanks
patty
uh it's great to to be here to share
today
with you northeastern university in in
boston's
response to covid19
um i'm the associate dean of professor
programs and graduate affairs
for the university but also the
technical supervisor for our life
science testing center which is the
testing center
i'm really going to focus on today
telling you about and how the university
spun that up
essentially in record time to provide a
response to copic 19.
at first though that i would start with
a little bit of background about
northeastern university in case you
don't
uh know northeastern you know the common
thing that i hear when i go any places
oh you work at northwestern like no
no nor eastern not northwestern although
we love northwestern too
so northeastern is a top 50 university
we're an r1 research university
we also have our number one career
services
interestingly northeastern is a
university with a global network so we
have
regional campuses in burlington mass
charlotte north carolina
london nahant massachusetts portland
maine san francisco
seattle silicon valley toronto ontario
and
vancouver british columbia which allows
us to really take advantage of the
global
nature of all of our industries
especially the sciences
northeastern was founded on a really
core concept
of experiential education what we call
the northeastern co-op
it's a little bit different than what
you might normally think about in terms
of a co-op yes it's a co-op a work
experience for students
but we have co-op faculty who help
students learn soft skills or what we
call power skills as well as develop
relationships with employers so that our
students can get jobs
and really help the students practice
interviews and things of this nature
we have approximately 5 000 faculty and
staff and somewhere around 28 000
students which i mentioned in the
context of
you know our testing protocol that we've
employed
so instead of an uh sort of instead of
an out
an outline of the presentation what i
thought i would give you is a timeline
of events
right the pandemic started
well some time ago but really in boston
we sort of shut down on march 13th
and the university went fully remote and
everybody had to take their
on ground classes and put them online
within several days
and then you can see over time that you
know there was a testing task force that
was instituted in april
we evaluated a number of just different
testing strategies
and then decided on an approach that we
were going to follow for the fall
semester fall
of 2020 which included the beginning of
the setup of the northeastern life
science testing center
in july that testing center was mass
state and clia licensed
and we took our first samples in august
so i'm going to go through this timeline
and break it out in the
coming slides so that you can understand
the process that we went through to get
to where we are today
september was optimization and october
is expansion
so just to recap in march the university
had to go fully remote actually i can
remember it vividly because i was
teaching an on-ground class from
march 9th through march 12th with
international regulators from all over
the world including africa asia latin
america
they got in just in time to get that
in-person training and got out just the
time before
the airports got harder to travel
through because there was less flights
so on march 13th the kobe 19 pandemic
caused northeast engine transition to
fully grown instruction
within two weeks after that all the
students were sent home and all
employees were moved to remote and not
exactly
all the majority of because research
continued at the university throughout
this time especially that research
related to cyrus cough to
any obviously business critical
events still continued if you have to be
in person
so in two days time essentially all the
on-ground classes working with
online which is not a small task um you
can imagine trying to take us the rest
of the semester
and put it online you know in a few days
and it was definitely a challenge
[Music]
so in april a sort of reorganization
or reopening committee was formed by the
university which consisted largely of
the senior leadership
and in that reopening or committee they
formed subcommittees
so the idea was for that committee to
monitor the current situation in
massachusetts and across the globe
because we have
campuses on global networks and then
decide what the course of action was
going to be for the university and out
of that one of the subcommittees that
was formed
in april was the testing task force
obviously that probably gives you a
pretty good idea of what the goal of
that
task force was to figure out
how testing would be part of our
reopening strategy of course
so the testing task force was formed and
and i was a member of it so i have
firsthand experience of what happened
in those conversations and we decided on
a four-pronged approach to testing or we
were absolutely
actually tasked with looking at four
different prongs
related to testing the first being could
we partner with a large diagnostic lab
to provide testing
for our students we were monitoring new
technologies or new tests that were
coming online that we might be able to
use
things like next generation sequencing
new
antigen or antibody tests coming out
could we partner with other institutions
in the region to sort of combine our
forces and
test together uh or should we set up our
own testing
so those are the four prongs that we
were we were looking at for
you know most of april into may
[Music]
so if you first think about partnering
with large diagnostic labs
it was a challenge because we had no
control over the turnaround time
or the variability in turnaround time so
if we sent our samples to
a large lab you know they gave us the
results when they could and if there
were stat samples or
samples from a hospital that took
priority ours would get pushed back
right so
we had no control over the turnaround
time we had to pay the
medicare or medicaid price and only one
test would
would probably get covered then the
university would have to pay the full
price which was some place on the order
of
90 to 110 dollars per test per person
per patient and at the time
back in april it was unclear if we'd be
able to do research repeat testing at
all
so those were a couple of things that we
considered when we looked at the large
diagnostic labs and we investigated that
option
pretty thoroughly just like all these
options
when it comes to monitoring new
technologies you know usually there
wasn't enough validation data
available for us to you know implement
that to keep the whole entire university
community safe which if you remember was
on the order of
33 000 people if everybody came back to
campus
there was no emergency use authorization
for many of the tests from the u.s
food and drug administration and the
timeline and scalability was unclear and
and the supply chain
as well was unclear on lots of these
technologies so we didn't know
if we would even be able to employ them
we looked at partnering with other
institutions most of our sister
institutions in the boston area the
large ones that decided to
either use the code which is part of mit
and harvard for testing
or they were affiliated with the medical
school and had
the ability to to just go ahead and do
their own testing rapidly
so you know we we sort of were stuck
between a rock and a hard place if you
will
in northeastern we don't have a medical
school um so
you know that's one if you want to call
it a disadvantage you could call that we
might have had
so you know that option was pretty much
eliminated from early on
so lastly we decided to look at setting
up our own testing lab
which we decided we would do in in
may actually we decided uh memorial the
friday before memorial day weekend this
would be the approach that we should
take
so it was named the life science testing
center or
lstc as i might call it moving forward
from memorial day until june 12th there
was further discussions to make sure
that this was the appropriate
decision to set up our own testing lab
and on june 12th
we actually began the process of setting
up the lab
as part of those conversations also we
wanted to decide on
what kind of tests we wanted to use if
we were going to set up our own
testing lab it's an important question
so of course we
considered both molecular diagnostic or
pcr-based tests
as well as sir loss with us largely
antibody based tests
through looking at through the
literature and information in in the
public domain
you know it became clear to us pretty
early on that pseudological tests were
not of the sensitivity or specificity
that we needed
so we decided to go ahead and create the
life science testing center as a high
complexity molecular diagnostic testing
lab
to start keeping in mind that we might
look at serological testing
or other types of tests to bring on
board in the future
like i mentioned on june 12th the
planning and the work began for the life
science testing center
northeastern had in the past have no
clinically certified labs on campus at
least of the high complexity molecular
diagnostic test
type we had one lab that was
able to do microscopy clinically but
that was it
so we decided to locate the life science
testing center on our innovation campus
in burlington massachusetts
the icbm is a 14 plus acre campus just
outside of the city of boston
that the university acquired from the
federal government in the 60s
so there's ample parking in and a new
building had just been built
where the biopharmaceutical analysis
laboratory or battle had been set up
and instituted and that's the lab that i
run and i encourage you to take a look
at the
the webpage the whole lot of activity
that goes on in battle that's
pretty exciting in the research and
education space
um so i had 2600 square feet of
unoccupied lab space and 1300 square
feet of
protein chemistry labs based that we
were going to repurpose into the life
science testing center
so we have the lab space that was
already built out and and
um unoccupied or no equipment
essentially in the space so we had a
blank blank slate so we at least had a
head start on there
on that but we had no other
infrastructure or anything ready to go
and we have to hire consultants to help
us
we decided to hire consultants to help
us with setting up our standard
operating procedures or sops
and to obtain state and clia
certification which was an important
part of us setting up the life science
testing center
at the core of everything that we do or
the foundation of everything that we do
with the lcc and my whole career has
been
really focused on quality when a lot of
my career has been based on bio
biopharmaceutical analysis and most
important thing to me is quality quality
quality
for patients and there's no difference
in the diagnostic space so quality and
accuracy are at the foundation of
everything that we do
we had to determine what type of test we
wanted to use the name of pharyngeal
interior nair or
other we had to acquire the equipment we
needed we had to hire and train a staff
we had to select a laboratory
information system you know we had to
design the sample workflow
and implement it we had to secure all
the testing supplies that we needed are
an extraction of pcr reagents
etc consumables and disposables which of
course was important for us to
gather and as you might all know the
supply chain for
anything related to coca testing is is
tight or restricted
so these were all things that we wanted
to get ahead of early on we had to do
produce validation so that we could be
certified
at our inspection so we had basically a
long laundry list of things to do
in a short amount of time because
obviously we wanted to have this
operation
for the start of our fall semester uh
classes started
after the wednesday after labor day
but students started moving in about 10
days before that so we have to be ready
for the end of august
as part of that we wanted to determine
what kind of reagents we were going to
use right i told you we decided to go
with a high complexity molecular
diagnostic test or a pcr based test
and we we validated or
validated but we investigated the
different tests were out there and
tried to pick the best test for the
highest quality or high specificity in
accuracy considering a few things as
well right because
not a ton is known about the virus and
the fidelity of the virus
even still but especially in a high risk
population
in terms of high risk i'm not talking
about you know
of illness or death but high risk
activities like going to parties or
you know hanging out with your friends
studying and not wearing a mask
so i didn't know or we weren't sure of
what possible mutations might crop up
in the in the viral genome
students recongregated in in close
proximity to each other
cdc protocol we looked at which you know
of course has
an rna sp control for human samples as
well as
two primers on the end gene um what you
can see here is
you know located towards the three prime
end
of the viral genome
i didn't really find that to be you know
the best test that we could use so we
scoured and looked for other options and
came across you know the applied
biosystems magmax viral pathogen
nucleic acid isolation kit as well as
the tacpath
kobe 19 combo kit right and this is all
in june
the thing that really i liked a lot
about the tack path
kit was two things really one that it
was multiplex
of different fluorescent signal for each
primer that was being used
so i could do all one patient in one
well and essentially confirm it in
triplicate
and that there was primers on the
orif-1ab gene
the s gene and the engine giving me you
know a better view of
what was happening in the viral genome
if there was changes being made
the way i describe it to my my friends
is basically saying the
you know imagine you're on a highway
with exit 1 through exit 10
you know the cdc test is basically my
exit 10 only
and the test that we decided to use this
tack path combo kit from thermo is
monitoring exit 2 6 and 10.
so it gives us better visibility and
confidence in the test result that we're
producing again quality quality quality
giving us
confidence in the quality of the result
that we're producing
so you know basically we
uh basically we enacted this simple
sample workflow the one recommended from
thermal fissure
sample collection we decided to go with
anterior nerve swabbing
nasopharyngeal would not
result in compliance from our student
population likely
but we figured and solving was was the
best case scenario
saliva had issues and wasn't at the
place where we were ready to consider it
obviously we purchased a number of
liquid handler robots to help with the
pipetting so that i didn't have to have
people pipetting thousands and thousands
of times in a day
we went with the applied biosav system
7500 fax
dx real-time pcr machine because it's
clinically certified or has clinical
use and practices so it can be uh iqoq
certified and then
um of course one of the great selling
points is the interpretive software for
coca-19 because that was our main focus
of the lab you know in the future we
think the lab will life science testing
center won't only be doing cover testing
we're hoping to be
able to implement a fluid fluid b test
perhaps the multiplex would be in covet
as well as other
diagnostic tests that are molecular
based but also looking at licenses for
antibodies and other things that we
provide as well as an
opportunity to do both clinical research
and and
you know diagnostic research and other
clinical research
[Music]
so from june 12th essentially to july
31st in six weeks
we set up the lab we hired an initial
staff of about 12 people
we validated all of our instruments and
workflows
and had our clea inspection or mass
state license inspection on july 31st so
that's
six weeks in total from
mustard seed if you will to complete
operating lab was
past inspection and ready to operate as
of noon on july 31st
and the consultants we use this was the
fastest they've ever done it in the 30
years they've been
uh in business of course i would if
you're a people fan and
remember the home run derby of sami
sosan
and mark mcguire the asters i would put
an asterisk here on
on the six weeks of course because uh
it's coveted and it was prioritized by
the state for
inspection obviously then we have to set
up the testing sites
so we set up a couple of testing sites
on the boston campus
one of them we call the cabot testing
center this is for routine surveillance
testing
we set this collection site up in two
weeks with a throughput
of or has the capacity of a throughput
of 8
600 samples per 12-hour day the maximum
that we've seen
go through there to date is 7 500 tests
and for whatever reason monday
seems to be the most popular day to have
a test
then we set up another testing center
the huntington testing center for
symptomatic testing
and we set that up in three weeks and
then our first sample
arrived in the lab on august 17th we
received 1500 samples that day
at 1 pm and then we were only operating
from 7 to 9 pm
[Music]
so like i mentioned we're using interior
nare swabs or and they're coming to us
drive where we add
viral transport media they're
transported to us the lstc by a medical
courier from boston
every test is ordered by a physician
students are tested
when they first return to campus on a
three-day cycle so day one day three and
day five
before they can enter class a class room
or do anything on campus after that
initial
set of tests the test students are
tested every three days
employees are who are on campus five
days a week are tested twice a week
we also test all nu community members
that includes employees
students and contractors so with the
three-day testing cycle
again one of the reasons we're going
with anterior and air swabbing is to
ensure
people comply with the testing
so if you look at the testing center by
the numbers at a
in operation and where we've come from
that august 17th date
till basically today right now we have
eight biological safety cabinets in
operation
we have seven liquid handlers in
operation nine qpcr machines running
approximately 7 500 clinical testing
staff
we have additional lab support we have
one supply chain manager
and actually the the lab support was
added
after the technical staff is uh as needs
arose so we have a supply chain manager
to mitigate
against supply chain risk like i
mentioned uh so
some things that are really hard for us
to get are pipette chips that have a
filter
because the filter itself is apparently
on backboard
so that's something hard for us to get
even biological safety cabinets are like
getting toilet paper at the beginning of
the pandemic very hard to do
so we have a supply chain manager
ensuring that we have continuity and
resilience and supply chain
follow the most important thing to me so
we have a qaqc manager to help
ensure that we're maintaining quality
and fall on our sops and all those great
things
we have the lab information system
manager to help us with the lab
information system
and processing you know making sure that
the results are released and processed
properly and understanding how to use
that system to best benefit
our community or our patients we have an
its manager for the lab to help with lab
instrumentation and other things
we realized really early on that you
know our goal is to process 5000
samples a day to be able to do that
realistically we have to move from a 12
or 14 hour day to 24 hour operations
seven days a week which is where we're
at today
[Music]
so you know we started on august
um 17th with around 1300 tests that day
i mean ideally i would have scaled up
from july 31st to
the end of august taking several hundred
tests the first week a thousand the
second to twenty five hundred the third
and so forth
um we were surprised by the number of
people who wanted to be
tested our forecasts didn't protect that
we predicted a hundred or so
folks on campus those first few weeks
that we tested
in reality people are very interested in
being tested and
making sure that they're covered or
stopped too negative
um so we weren't able to scale up in
that fashion
um but what we were able to do is
process those 1300 tests per day for the
first several weeks
and then um we are also using the broad
institute as
a it's a good business practice to have
resiliency in our testing
regime so something happens to them or
the lstc we have backup
so for a weekend we sent all of our
almost all of our samples to the road so
that the life science testing centers
could
uh get her feet under her that was just
the sort of the uh
the weekend of august 24th or around
there
and then started operating again on that
monday
taking about 1500 samples a day and
scaling it up to 2500 and then by the
beginning of september
we're able to process 5000 tests per day
and we've been doing 5 000
or between five hundred and five
thousand tests per day
um for the last days uh
actually we process all of our tests on
the weekends now
um and we send uh
less than forty percent of our tests
abroad this week we're doing a capacity
experiment to see how many tests we can
actually profits in a 24-hour period
um and this is the week of october uh
fifth and we were able to process 6500
tests in a 24-hour period
and then hopefully moving towards
october we're going to be able to
process even more tests in a 24-hour
period on the order of 13 to 16 000
tests
per 24 hours
um
we also decided because we're doing our
own testing it would be cool if we could
use it for research opportunities so we
do have irb approval for a research
repository and registry
so that we can have a better
understanding of probit 19 preventing
the next pandemic
and validating new diagnostics coming
out of labs and and other places
partnering really to do exactly that
understand cover 19 and preventing the
next pandemic so
we are also able to do research that's
the beauty of working in academic
institution and having a
testing center here um
and then like i mentioned in october we
want to get to about 13 000 to 16 000
samples per day
so um you know at um
noon on october 8th or so
we were given our temporary certificate
of occupancy for a 3250 square foot lab
expansion
that lab expansion will include eight
additional biological safety cabinets
six additional liquid handlers and six
additional
qpcr machines we haven't previously
hired enough staff
to train um in the old space so that we
could expand into the new space and be
ready to go
and are considering currently what uh
might be available for us to test
outside of the northeastern community
including
local communities around the university
or other
you universities with this increased
capacity as well as if there's
uh need from the government at some
point
so in our four-pronged strategy it's
still
right like we plan for the fall semester
but what's going to happen in the spring
and we're just we're trying to figure
that out now i mean we took partner with
large diagnostic labs sort of off the
off the list we won't pursue that as an
option
we are still monitoring new technology
generation sequencing and point of care
tests you know your sort of paper-based
tests
and and rapid response tests uh it
at the very least to reduce the number
of pcr based tests that we have to do
um you know sort of
to to do a two-pronged approach not
replacing peace there but helping with
that
we're still looking at how we might
partner with other institutions more
from the
how we can help them as opposed to them
helping us standpoint
and other that we might uh help test for
you know we want to reduce the number of
pcr tests we're doing so we're looking
at other options like pooling
serological tests plus pcr like i just
mentioned
in are exploring those to see if there's
any added value
we are looking at like i mentioned the
fluid fluid covet combo test which we
would deploy for symptomatic patients
as the flu season sort of kicks up in
the winter comes upon us in new england
and we're expecting more people to be
inside and people to get sick so we want
to
be able to perform at least the flu and
kova test as they're sick and
of course we're looking at other
opportunities lab could provide
for testing so with that
it was great to tell you about our
journey towards reopening the campus
this fall
and beyond and the strategies that
eastern took
to do that i'm really proud of the fact
that
you know the senior leadership has
allowed us to put quality at the
forefront of
everything that we do um providing
quality tests and keeping
the university safe and um you know
over the last seven days in this week of
october 5th i'm happy to say that our
infect
effectivity right on campus is less than
0.02 which is
really exciting and we do have our own
contact tracing
as well that's allowing us to keep
control of campus
so with that i thank you for your time
thank you dr arclaire it's such an
inspirational story to hear how this
program was pulled together from concept
back in april
and how it's developed into the strategy
it is today to support the health of the
university
community now let's pivot over to the
industry side
and hear how everly wells home
collection enables a healthy return to
office
we are excited to have dr frank along
here today
dr ong is a chief medical and scientific
officer at everly well
the digital health company poised to
disrupt the lab testing industry
by providing consumers with an at-home
testing kit
that includes insightful easy to
understand results dr ong leads the
company's medical affairs
including clinical laboratory operations
research
and clinical development including new
test development
prior to joining everly well dr ong held
leadership positions at garden health
giant roche diagnostics and illumina
and served as a faculty member and
researcher at cedar sinai medical center
where he received research grants from
the nih
he earned his medical degree from the
keck school of medicine
at the university of southern california
and holds graduate certificates in
clinical and translational investigation
bio bile design and medical device
innovation
in clinical trial administration from
stanford university
ucla in university of california san
diego
he served his residency in the
department of family medicine
at ucla geffen school of medicine
and he resides today in austin texas
thanks for joining us today dr aang
i'll let you take it from here thank you
patty
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
this session on back to work school and
life
utility of cuba 19 testing to help
communities restore
in this session we're going to briefly
review the background of cobit 19
the state of covenanting testing as well
as
how to develop a program to get
communities back
on track the situation is that we have
the cobia 19 emergency being quite fluid
in nature
so please do inform or refer to
information provided by your federal
cdc or public health officials and
government authorities for continued
guidance
and another point of disclaimer for the
every world culver 19 test home
collection kit
it is authorized by the fda under eua
it has not been fda cleared or approved
this home collection kit has been
authorized only for the home collection
and maintenance of nasal swab specimens
as an aid in detection of nucleic acid
from stars code b2
and not for any other viruses or
pathogens
my name is dr frank aung i am the chief
medical incentive officer of evelywell
and at everly well we empower people
and organizations with at home health
care that is
comprehensive trusted and actionable
so briefly on qubit 19 as all of you
know
the cases continue to rise across the
united states as of end of september
we are at a total case of over 7 million
with total deaths of over 200 000 and
just the last week of september
we logged over 300 000 cases
the numbers continue to rise in this
first week of october
briefly the kova 19 uh sarge kobe 2
virus
can take anywhere from 2 to 14 days
for symptoms to appear after infection
and as
all of you probably know a good
proportion of individuals
who are infected are in fact
asymptomatic
carriers not exhibiting any signs
of symptoms such as cough or runny nose
we are not sure at this point whether a
history of stars cov2
guarantees or does not guarantee
immunity from future infection
and just a few days ago we had
confirmation from the cdc
with regards to the air droplet and
airborne transmission of the virus
obviously the most important risk factor
for
infection is close contact with someone
that is infected
in the times of covid businesses are
charged with protecting
their participants in the latest review
from the american journal of public
health
three-quarters of american workers are
at risk for increased exposure
by working on sites or experiencing job
uncertainty
because of workplace closure
almost 50 percent of employers say that
they are
they have employees or participants are
afraid to return to work
and the estimated cost of employee
benefits for workers who are absent from
work
total 23 billion dollars
you've probably seen or heard uh in the
media
about the need for organizations to
implement testing strategies as they
consider
safe methods for expanding on-site
opportunities one very obvious group is
the employers
and i'll share more about safe
back-to-office methods
for employers in a bit the need for
increased
kova testing at schools is becoming more
obvious
especially given the fact that the cac
reported
just in the few weeks in late august
that the increase in the person's age 18
to 22 for cova cases
was almost 50 to 55 this aligns very
much with this time frame when many went
back to school
additionally it was confirmed by cdc
that in-flight transmission of coronal
virus is possible
and so we've seen airlines offering
testing for cobia 19 before flight
especially for international
travel to design a program that works
it is different for each organization
what that looks like
first we need to understand uh the
government guidelines from the federal
level
from cdc and hss to state and local
public health officials and authorities
next we need to look at what type of
testing and how much of testing is
necessary
for each group or organization and the
type of testing ranges from pcr testing
to antibody serology testing direct or
rapid antigen testing
or a combination of all three we also
need to look at the support
that the organization needs whether they
have in-house medical staff
or a fully outsourced model and the risk
tolerance level for each organization
and this really depends on each
organization's and
employee composition the commute
behavior
location and structure of the actual
office space
and the health and the demographics of
your participants
and employees
the copenhagen testing goals ranges from
the health and safety of employees and
customer first
to a comprehensive solution and finally
to efficiently return to the office
space
in terms of the primary goal for
employees and customers health
there needs to be a triage for those who
need immediate care
and then remote management of those with
mild to moderate symptoms
with cobit positive cases through the
quarantine period
in terms of the comprehensive solution
it is a choice between ongoing
surveillance and screening
every few weeks to a protocol that is
single use testing and screening
and most importantly the data collection
reporting to
state and local authorities as well as
contact tracing
from the positive cases that result from
the testing
finally in terms of efficiently
returning to office we need to have a
clinical protocol
developed with regards to those that
have previously tested positive and
recovered
those that are currently infectious as
well as the ones that
may have already been infected and may
have
immediately conferred upon them
next i want to talk about the ugly well
digital health platform and how that
works with cobia 19 testing
so first of all the everywhere digital
health platform helps organizations
facilitate
at-home healthcare with a seamless
end-to-end solution
it is a comprehensive end-to-end
solution that we offer from handling the
test distribution the actual kit
to monitoring the testing status at
every step along the way
and finally with regards to evaluating
and displaying
reviewing results we work with the
highest quality testing labs that are
clia certified and cap accredited
and everywhere was the first digital
health company to receive an at-home
cobia 19 eua
that was not tied to a specific lab or
a specific manufacturer of the test
the results from our tests are
actionable and they are accurate
it is on our digital platform that
empowers the participants to take action
on their health
while giving the organizations access to
keep those testing reports
even though not related to kobe 19 i
want to point out two examples
one of which was with a health plan a
major health plan
with regards to diabetes testing and
monitoring
and where we noticed and the health plan
noticed that testing compliance rates
increased by 48 year-over-year from
non-compliant members
another example was for colorectal
screening and then with another major
health plan
where positive fit or fecal
immunochemical test results
were twice more likely the members that
received those positive results were
twice more likely
to see a doctor versus the previous
comparator
and this is a result of again the
platform being easy to use for both the
participants and for organizations
participants can easily order the tests
through our web page they have a simple
instruction that make apple collection
easy and they view and keep their
results and data
and can refer to that at any time for
the organizations
the ships the tests are shipped directly
to the participant's home
everywhere lens enables viewing of each
participant's test status
and there are alerts of abnormal results
that are delivered
immediately
in terms of the workflow the shipment
and the purchase goes out
the participant registers once that
happens
a third party physician network
authorizes that requisition
the sample is collected at home sent to
the partner labs
and processed the results are then
reviewed by the physician
and then finally push back to the user
uh or the consumer
through our views viewable and is
viewable by organization participants
this platform makes it possible for
organizations to improve business
continuity
and keep participants safe during covert
19.
an example of how our digital health
platform has helped
in the time of copa 19 is the use case
for the city of la
there were 160 sites across the city of
la that participated in this initiative
and over 70 000 clover 19 test home
collection kits were distributed
you can see here from the chief medical
officer for the la jewish home
that the best summary and this is quote
the best summary of the evil process is
this
your work is helping to save lives
during this unprecedented
unprecedented pandemic through every
well we have been able to
test both asymptomatic residents and
staff and we've been able to effectively
stop the spread of virus across 1600
staff
and 1100 residents by catching it early
so everybody well we created
a medicare compliant infrastructure in a
complex lab
testing industry we've worked with and
we are continuing to work with clio
certified and capricorn lab network
including our own kappa creative lab
we have a network of cobot 19 testing
labs and we also have
a partnership with thermal fissure as
well
this extensive quality assurance and
monitoring
and testing is very important for the
accuracy of the results
and fast turnaround time for the
patients
the process again is physician reviewed
and customer supported
the diagnostic panels include the
physician consults
and prescription and all the results
discussions
are handled with registered health care
professionals
we also have an in-house clinical team
that supports
questions and this demonstrates a high
net promote
promoter score which is customer
satisfaction in a nutshell
you can think of ugly well as the lift
of uber connecting
consumers employees students athletes et
cetera
to laboratory network for cova 19
testing
so we help by focusing on what matters
most and that's sample processing
we also have a very transparent flat
fee per sample no hassle with insurance
we manage the supply and demand and
provide the end user a consumer with the
kits and
components for collection electronic
orders through the
laboratory network makes the receiving
session seamless
results are reported electronically and
we handle all user-facing results
content and questions
to summarize every well has low error
rates and high customer satisfaction
the issue rates are under five percent
and again the net promoter score
is over 70. we have a dedicated team
ready to resolve issues that require
follow-up
and that's missing information and
correct names etc
the quantity not sufficient remark
with regards to kits are then
automatically
sent a replacement kit for the end users
our lab api and portal allows for sample
issues to be tracked
and so there's no need for a manual
handoff
we have unique unique kit id barcode
that links the electronic lab order
ensuring results are tied to the correct
order and we have patient identifiers
that are verified upon receipt for the
samples
ensuring that the right samples are
matched with the right
results thank you for your time
and i'm happy to take any questions at
this time
thank you dr kong for sharing the everly
well story from hearing about university
testing
and employer testing today i hope our
participants come away
with some effective strategies for
establishing testings
to help your communities come back to
school back to work
back to life and know that thermo fisher
is a partner to you in finding the right
testing solutions
to help you and your communities
re-establish
that sense of normality thank you for
joining us today
you